foreign
today we will take you through a hands
of lab demo of how we can analyze
WhatsApp group chat using machine
learning
before we start I hope this skin is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join until then let me tell
you guys that we have regular updates
and multiple Technologies if you are a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for the
latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn okay great I think we can get
started
so let's move to the programming part
here we will type
Jupiter
notebook
and press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and it select open new python
file here we will go new pattern file
so this is how the python Journal look
likes jupyter python gonna look like so
here first we will change the name
WhatsApp
group
okay
yes
so here first we will import some major
libraries
but first we will import import
re regular expression and then import
Rejects
I will explain one by one
so don't worry import
ance
at PD
report
numpy as ND
and the fifth one is
import
ant
dot Express
as PX
okay
then from collection
import
ant
okay and import
my plot live
Dot Pi plot
as PLT
okay this is for the graph
and from
OS
import
and the next one is from pil
then this is the major One Import
date
time
and this one is important
word cloud
.cloud
Mass top words
upwards and then
image
color
editor
okay
then person
matplotlib
[Music]
and press enter let's see
uh collection
could be collections
[Music]
from word cloud import toward Cloud
stopwatch image color generator
yeah so cannot import name but Cloud
okay sorry
it should be small
okay so rest is fine
so Nampa is a python Library used for
this one numpy it's a python Library
used for working with arrays it also has
a functions for working in the domain of
Lillian algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numpy stand for numerical python
and the panda panda is a software
Library written for the Python
programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structure and operations
for manipulating numerical tables and
Time series
this matplotally by plot
so for Python and its numerical
extension number mad problem is a
cross-platform data visualization and
graphical charting package as a result
it represents
a strong open source substitute for
multiplayer
the application programming interface
format probably allow programmers to
incorporate graphs into giu application
okay
then this re regular expression
so a regular expression is specify a set
of string that matches it the function
in this module let you check if a
particular string matches a given
regular expression or not
or you can say if a given regular
expression matches a particular string
which come down
to the same thing
okay
X
regex or angular expression is a
sequence of character that forms a
search platform
okay or you can just search better can
be used to check if a string contains a
specified search pattern or not
and this PX
okay totally Express
this broadly Express module usually
imported as PX contains functions that
can create entire figure at once okay
and is refers to as a plotly Express or
PX
plotly Express is a built-in part of the
daily library and
it is recommended the starting point for
creating the most common figures
okay then there is one more this counter
Library so the counter is a dick
subclass for counting hashable objects
it is a collection where elements are
stored as a directory
keys and their counts are stored as a
dictionary values okay counts are
allowed to be any integer value
including 0 or negative counts
okay then there is one more this word
cloud okay this is the kind of major one
to visualize so
not major one but it looks good at the
end you will see so what cloud is a data
visualization technique used for
representing Text data in the which size
of each word indicates its frequency or
importance
significant textual data points can be
highlighted using word cloud
our clouds are widely used for analyzing
data from social network websites okay
then stopwards
a stopwatch is a commonly used word such
as the uh and in so that a search engine
has been programmed to ignore both
indexing entries for searching and when
retrieving them as a result in a search
query okay
so let's proceed further and create
the various function for the author for
the date and time for the get data time
for the
you know data point for the Android and
for the iOS like things like that Okay
so
here I will write Def
TS
with
it
and
time
okay
it starts with date and time okay
I will write here pattern
right pattern
question
this if this
I will write here
zero time
okay
like that 0 to 9 plus
if
different stuff
again
these are the 40 numbers okay
us
yes
P.M
okay
oh
I am
okay so result
equals to
Rd dot match
if result
done
or else return
let me give some space for the better
visual
yeah
so now we will find the author okay
we'll create function for the author
Def
fine
author
okay
then here I will write s equals to
plot
it
then
if
and of s
question two
that
okay
and
return
well
now what will will create a function to
get data point for the Android line okay
so here I will write Def
get
data point
right
nine
and date
time equals to
plate
line
and date comma 2.
time
equals to
date
time dot display
then message
was soon
dot join to like split line it
is
headline
Auto
which
dot split
print
or turn
goes to split
page
thank you
message
question
dot join
it
message
Auto
question
and
eight comma
okay
so this is the uh for the getting data
point for the Android okay language line
just for the uh I will like
copy pasted and this is for the this one
iOS okay
so in this we are doing the same like
straight line the same we did for the
you know Android okay
so
moving forward
will create a function for the split
count
okay
so for that today text here
I can like emoji
Lambda
then why
then again
g dot use
English
dot keys
okay
regex
that's true
re Dot
compile
drag and write join
other Dot
Escape
pm
or em
oji
index I'm just going to set
Dot and all
yes
enter yeah
so now we will import our data okay so
we will
make a list to keep a track of data so
it can be used for the you know pandas
data frame
and we'll
it will create a separate every column
for the daytime author and message okay
so the major thing is okay let's import
data first then I will tell you
okay so this is the list to keep a track
of data so it can be used for the data
frame under database okay so like
Converse
conversation path
so my file name is WhatsApp
dad
because he's captain
good
and placed
student
[Music]
P22
dog
this is my file
so how you can export your chat from
your WhatsApp bro okay so this is the
data this is my personal data so I can't
give you so how you can import your text
your chat okay so open any group
just click on the top right corner
I'll get three dots then you can go into
mode and then you can explore chat
including media and excluding media your
wish okay so you can download you can
send to the mail you can upload in the
drive then you can use in your machine
learning project okay so I will write
these all these steps in the description
box below so don't worry
going forward
let's do
a bun
conversation
coding
costume
UTF
eight
you know then device
question
first
let's do FB Dot readline
print
first
if
base question I
or else
twice
question
and
P Dot
read line
message
okay
come on time comma author
none
message content four things date Time
author message okay so for the message
this is the message buffer and for the
so while
dot read line
not
line
if y says
device which will go to iOS
pursue
dot strip
it and
time iOS
fine
start with date time iOS line so here I
will cast
data
Dot
if
okay so this is the long
entered here
so
so what we did we created if devices iOS
so the line strip will come and the
function starts with date time and iOS
this one we created already
okay it will capture the date Time
author and messages
okay then at the end the message buffer
will append okay for the both
foreign
Panda's data frame okay list
so let's go ahead and see okay while Dre
okay
stop with pattern is not defined
foreign
pattern
so
okay
and data point Android line
maybe the spelling mistake as you can
see
Point get data point Android is capital
and this
40 line get data pointed right
we copied from here
copy
and
let me run it
line okay
we split line split line is not defined
okay let me get back to you
so as you can see everything is sorted
so
here you can see this is the group name
okay brtn PlayStation 2022. and this is
date
and this is time and this is the guy who
created the group okay
so here I will write if
device
project also
Android
and
DF equals to PD
Dot
data frame
pass data
tolerance question
eight
let's
follow
[Music]
and DF
eight
I'm setting the columns PD dot to
date time
PF
okay
then URL
pattern
uh
then https
Plus
so again after DF equals to for the URL
count
from
button okay
you should be capital
comma X
PRL
string length
so
it's fine then after it else
so here we are like initializing the
data frame Panda's data frame so DF
equals to PD Dot
data frame
because
data comma
columns
question
date
comma
time
for authors
yeah
so this is the Panda's data frame we
have another site
that DF equals to DF dot drop and
here
date
dot apply
and
because
if it
also
if
time
okay comma format
let's just hear
okay percentage here
that
and URL
pattern
equals to
yes
that cannot assigned to literal well
copy it paste it
turning
so now let's see the data set so DF dot
head
20.
first 20 rows of the data frame
as you can see
see uh this guy doctor something related
power so he sent the message greetings
about the date from and in this there is
one URL
okay
and this is the date and this is time
when he sent uh when she sent
Okay so this there are three links in
these two links okay
is this related to placement this guy
sent okay
so these are the top 20.
the number of links you can see in the
particular message two three and then
the zero zero this is the media okay so
I downloaded
uh the chat without media okay you can
chat you can come using media
let's see the information
data
so this is you can see we have five
column name date Time author message URL
count Okay so
I'll count date time this is object and
this is object and URL count as n64.
okay
let's see all the author names only
author names so here I will add DF Dot
of us Dot
unique
okay
my bad
these are the authors all the authors
number of members you can say in
particular uh group
okay
these are all are the unique authors so
moving forward let's see the you know
like let's drop all the null values so
for that we have to write DF dot equals
to TF dot drop n
so
top end is done and so these are the
some basic you can say the function of
machine learning and python
okay
and moving forward let's see the total
messages total
yes
plus two
DF dot shape
we're going to print
87 total messages okay the media
messages
h
onestly
yeah
let me do
yep zero
paint
media
why this is 0 I already told you like
I export chat without media okay
so you can export with media too okay
so
right here URL
button
okay
so this is the you can say the regex
pattern this one
okay this is the rejects pattern
and with the start with the St https and
the second one this this URL count
return URL which matches with pattern
and counts it through the all the Lambda
function
okay now I will write one more thing
sum
but
yeah
what this will do this is sum up all the
links okay so print
links
as you can see there are 47 links in the
group chat
okay so moving forward let's uh let us
separate and media messages and the text
message okay so this is the
is the code for that so link message you
go to URL count okay
deleted messages and this message was
deleted okay both the statement
and this media omitted this image okay
this video for the video and this is
stickers and we send okay then the drop
any deleted messages and the link
message okay so for that let's press
enter and
that's it
underscore DF
Dot
okay
so now you can see we deleted dropped
all the you can say the deleted messages
or the link messages okay as you can see
87 now 56 only
okay
so let's
calculate words and letters okay
for that messages underscore DF
then
rent account
that account then it was your messages
PF
and
message
bye
live you can see
okay
I will write here messages
or DF then word count
it is underscore DF
h
Dot
print
okay messages
EF then
message count
one
okay
so here you can see I wrote here split
so word count will be count as like the
space you can see space between the
words
okay splitting sentence with the white
space you can say
okay
let's see
sh underscore DF
Dot
at 10 press enter
here I have to write messages
yeah
so now you can see this author sang
this letter count 25 and the word count
is this and the message count is 1 only
so this package test dot things and this
is strange this doctor this Arjun hiring
work from home kind of things and the
light account is 201 then one count 31.
okay and this is something hexa viewed
things and okay so these are the words
and letters we calculate
okay now we will see the stats uh like
author wise okay for that I will write
the code and we'll get back to you after
that
so this is the code for the you can say
stats
okay there's an error
word count
okay
okay so these are the all the stats per
user per author you can say message sent
and words per message and media media
sent is zero because like I haven't you
know included media in my chat so that's
fine
okay the words per message this and
these all the stats you can see and let
me explain you the code
so this is for the like filtering you
know filtering out the message for the
particular user
this message DF message DF author
friends
and for this
like rqdf will contain messages of only
one particular user so we are printing
that okay
um
this shape this one so uh shall we print
the number of rows which indirectly mean
the number of messages
okay
so this word count this word count
so word count contains all the total
words in one message sum of all the
words divided by total messages will
yield what's per message okay so and
this is for the media messages this is
zero and this is for the link consists
of the total links Okay so
this is all the data so now moving
forward times of the data let's see the
times of the day so in this time the
most message is gone like this so
message is
so DF
that is
time
Dot
value
paragraph Okay horizontal
than PLT dot X label
that
is
and PLT dot y level
and times of the day at which the most
number of message sent
okay
this is your top 10 uh
so because of
okay let me do like this now it's good
time a number of messages okay this is
it
what I can do is
number of messages and the top 10 time
most number of messages now the time is
came to see the word cloud okay
now we'll make the word cloud so for
that I will let me give
text
pursue
dot join
or join
you can say review
print
is much words
or the
okay
dot format
will be length
and then stop words
one of my favorite
set
stop words
then we will generate the world cloud
this is to generate the world cloud
okay sorry word cloud
but cloud
upwards
background
White
Dot
it
yes
so we'll display the generated image and
deploy using the you know matte broadly
way so clear the dot figure
eyes
let's
say
population
equals to
set it by linear
by linear and
PLT dot axis
PLT dot issue
based upwards rate
as you can see there are nine two three
five words in all the messages
so these are the sums the Gmail password
pressure and it's ready
test email and there's a student
and see something like this These Are
the World Cup
okay so what if I want to see the
particular author name World cloud like
how many messages he sent and all like
it so
this is the doctor okay I took from here
no issues
so let's see
so this is uh author doctor
he sent hiring jobs and fresher student
and this is Anusha ready joined and save
the Chandra already join okay so this is
how you can analyze and you can see
data uh you can analyze your WhatsApp
group data okay I will add all the
you know steps how to you how you can
explore the chat okay
so I hope you guys understand how we can
analyze the WhatsApp group data okay
what's a group chat data using machine
learning and python if you have any
question you can ask in the comment
section below okay our team will respond
you as soon as possible and don't forget
to check the all the courses link from
the description box below if you want
this full code just comment for the same
I can't provide you the data set you are
I but I will provide the steps how you
can download the data set for your own
it will be fun you can
uh analyze your transcript data who sent
this message and that message okay
thank you so much for being here
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
give like to this video thank you and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you